[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
weitere grill marinade von mir wir
machen eine marinade für alle hähnchen
arten ich mache daraus heute schießt
auch das ist er also türkisch also hebt
ihn spiels auf die türkische art und ihr
könnt das grillen ihr könnt auch auf den
kontakt zu legen in den backofen in die
pfanne was auch immer er möchte die
stadt jetzt direkt mit dem fleisch ich
schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier
unterlief kurz info box da könnt ihr
euch direkt screenshot ist das viel
einfacher und das ganze direkt nach
machen ich werde jetzt hier meine
hähnchenbrust schneiden ist immer besser
wenn ihr entgegengesetzt der faser
schneidet ich mache es so dass ich nicht
ganz kleine stücke schneiden sie sollten
schon ein bisschen dicker sein sie
müssen auch auf dem spieß halten können
aber im grunde genommen ist das auch
komplett euch überlassen
hähnchenbrust ist vorbereitet jetzt
geht's an die marinade das wird nur
marinade auf basis von joghurt und
olivenöl daher gebe ich joghurt also ich
habe jetzt hier 35 prozentigen natur und
den gebe ich schon mal rein in eine
ausreichend große schüssel dann gleich
wird darin alles mariniert doch ist
alles reinpassen
olivenöl da nimmt bitte gutes
kaltgepresstes leckeres olivenöl mainz
verlinke ich euch in die infobox dann
was bei mir niemals fehlen darf das ist
knoblauch und anschließend auch noch ein
bisschen paprika markt
[Musik]
meine gewürze sind kreuzkümmel sehr
wichtig und ich liebe kreuz könne
weiteres gewürz was nicht fehlen darf
ist zu mag das ist es essig baum gewürzt
schmeckt zum befüllen säuerlich aber so
eine angenehme säure ist das auf jeden
fall noch mit rein jetzt gebe ich hier
noch paprikapulver treibt einmal das
edelsüßer und davon gibt ein bisschen
mehr rein eine pool die welt das ist so
diese türkische art von paprika flocken
das ist auch ein bisschen schärfer und
das mag ich ganz gerne und da gibt es
zwar auch nicht zu viel rein ich mag es
nämlich nicht so scharf und dann
natürlich salz und pfeffer verrühren
einfach alles miteinander
[Musik]
ich habe ich alles gut miteinander
verbunden und ich liebe diese tiefrote
farbe
das sieht jetzt schon so schmackhaft
haus und jetzt müssen wir das kühlen bzw
einfach ziehen lassen diese ganzen
gewürze schön einziehen und das auch auf
dem grill später sehr sehr gut schmeckt
aber das ist doch das entspannte am
grillen man kann es wirklich am vorabend
alles vorbereiten alles in den
kühlschrank stellen und am nächsten tag
ist man gar keine arbeit mehr und grillt
ist einfach nur wobei dieses rezept wie
gesagt könnt ihr auch im backofen etc
machen ich mache jetzt den deckel einmal
zu also mindestens vier stunden wäre
schon ganz gut ansonsten auch super
gerne über nacht und danach spielt sich
das einfach aufstieg spitze auf
[Musik]
so die hähnchenspieße können jetzt ganz
einfach direkt gegrillt werden macht
gerne so dass sie erst auf die heißeste
stellen liegt also in die mitte des
grills und dann alle drei minuten wendet
das ganze dauert also circa 18 bis 20
minuten je nachdem wie dick sie sind ich
mache auch gerne so dass ich sie ihn am
anfang auf die heiße stellen lege und
dann wirklich außen da wo nicht so viele
zuvor ist zuende gare damit die auch
richtig schön saftig bleiben die
marinade ist auf jeden fall super lecker
probiert unbedingt mal auf wie sich sein
davon oder hansa
hat kein mikrofon aber stimmt mir zu
also ganz viel spaß ihm nachmachen und
bis zum nächsten oder zwei videos eure
ki
[Musik]